is the Super Bowl halftime show an
homage to the Babylonian God Bale also
symbolized by a golden calf or is some
of the occultt symbolism just pure
coincidence let's do a deep dive one of
the most popular American shows in
history is the Super Bowl Super Bowl
halftime show I believe this is
literally a worship ceremony to Satan
what do you guys think do you guys agree
or I have seen a number of them over the
years and yes there seems to be a thread
through the mall a lot of people
watching it a lot of people pay
attention to it a lot of people they say
it's the largest stage that you can get
to if you are performing during the
Super Bowl you have it you have arrived
yes so so let's look at three people and
first one being Madonna and let's see
what she says and let's let's look at
these performances that have happened in
the past and you know maybe maybe not
there will be something similar with
Super Bowl 2025 Kendrick Lar
so let's take a look at bonna see what
she says about Super Bowl first of all
it's the Super Bowl I mean the Super
Bowl is kind of like the holy of holies
in America right so like here I am I'm
going to come into like the half halfway
between like the the the church the
church experience and I'm going to have
to deliver a sermon that's going to be
have to be very impactful at the time
Madonna may have seemed like an odd
choice for the 2012 Super Bowl but then
again Madonna is no stranger to
performing a cult ritual during her
performances whether she's surrounded by
demons dancing with scantily clad nuns
who are stripping on poles in the shape
of a crucifix or delivering an a cult
sermon in probably the most offensive
and blasphemous performance I have ever
seen in my
[Applause]
life what you look
don't
stand don't
stand then you are to
[Music]
St wow so were all the clips uh from
this one yeah this is like show on the
cross the nuts that was actually a
different performance yes but she she's
done multiple of these quite Blasphemous
yes there was one picture where she was
sitting with the uh she was dressed up
as as Jesus or think something like that
at the Lord's supper and there's like I
don't know it's weird you're talking
about the where she had the crown of
thorns around her head she might have
had that there I mean she was hanging on
the cross and the very interesting thing
is she came down off the cross I mean it
was like the most Blasphemous stuff you
could come up with yeah uh at least
she's honest she said it's a church and
she's going to give a sermon yeah sermon
for Satan so what what is what do we do
at the church what what does it mean the
impact on people when you hear a sermon
at the church yeah I mean supposed to
change
changing like it's a message from above
but who do they worship who do they
follow um it it's I think it's pretty
obvious that she's not a Christian and
if she is she's definitely not showing
the fruits so who who is she showing to
follow and to have have given her heart
to you know if you could go back in time
and you could look at like Babylonian
worship ceremonies way back in ancient
cultures there was an element of they
always had Temple prostitutes and stuff
like this right they did
they are incorporating a lot of these
ancient ideas she's bringing Egypt into
this yeah she's bringing a lot of
Blended cultures and basically tur it
into a church ceremony and this is
interesting you brought up Babylon
because if you look at the major empires
in history right Babylon was considered
one of one of the first world Empires
and it's actually a prophecy in Daniel 2
chapter 2 in the Bible that talks about
what um Empires were going to follow
suit what I find interesting and what I
find really cool is that this was
written when by Daniel who was actually
a high up official in the courts of
Babylon but he was a Hebrew and he wrote
this down when he when Babylon was still
the sole power yeah it was the head of
the gold yes but um eventually these
other powers came into being well we
find historical evidence that Daniel was
a real character he was actually living
under nebuch nezzar and then some other
you know Babylonian Kings after that
there's historical evidence that
Daniel's book is true and that the Bible
prophesied foretold what kingdoms would
follow now eventually after Babylon you
had Meo Persia that took over and it got
bigger and then you had Greece taking
over it got bigger and then you had Rome
taking over and it got bigger and this
is literally what she's portraying here
right she's portraying the Spartans that
are carrying which like you said goes
back to Babylon like it's all been been
coming down and now here she's
portraying this kind of stuff she knows
what she's doing MH you know 100% And
then also at the end of the clip you saw
this guy throw up the the the the horn
sign like the devil sign which people
say oh it's just a symbol of rock and
roll no it's not it's a symbol of Satan
it's the horns of the baffet um you know
image all right so let's look at the
next one Katy Perry now this is a clip
from a video that we've done before this
one and the next one about Beyonce that
we're going to cover as well there uh
from a video you can watch on YouTube
about 10 10 celebrities who sold their
soul let's take a look what she's up to
Katie whose real name is Catherine
Elizabeth Hudson grew up as a PK or
pastor's kid with two Evangelical
Christian pastors as parents in her
sheltered home she wasn't allowed to
check out rly music artists we knew
about the Donna and Marilyn mans in my
family because we picked at their
concerts once while handing out
pamphlets at a Manson concert Perry went
inside and to her surprise found it
really interesting and weird I got it
she said it's notable that Katie Perry
shares to have found Marilyn Manson who
was a priest of the Church of Satan
interesting because years later she said
this yeah I mean I released a gospel
record when I was 15 um because I grew
up in uh you know a household where all
I ever did was listen to gospel music
and my parents are both traveling
ministers and so I kind of sang about
you know what was going on in my life at
15 and that's how I got introduced to
the music industry I swear I wanted to
be like the Amy Grand of music yeah but
it didn't work out and so I sold my soul
to the devil Katie Perry is now known to
throw around a lot of satanic ult and
Pagan symbols including references to
Egyptian gods freem imagery such as the
checkered board at her Super Bowl
performance snakes which according to
the Bible is a symbol of Satan and
Aliens which actually is a reference to
[Applause]
Demons Super Bowl are you ready
to you know there's a lot of like
Christian imagery that she was
displaying the cross on her chest which
is super like Blasphemous but she was
getting burned on this the br's broom or
something surrounded by dark beings yeah
and her riding in on a beast like this
where she's like on fire and she's like
the woman that's riding the beast I mean
there's a lot of like Christian sort of
ideas being incorporated into her work
but super
Blasphemous sad and and and the Super
Bowl is traditionally like you know it's
it's it's kind of a family event for for
sort of a historical families would get
together and watch this so you got a lot
of kids watching this and if America
truly is this like Christian Nation
you're throwing some imagery out here
that I think is completely Blasphemous
oh yeah I mean I I many people would say
oh I'm never I would never go to you
know uh to a seance or anywhere where
they would worship Satan I would never
watch anything where they're outward
worshipping the devil but then everyone
gathers together to watch probably the
most watched musical of the year the
Super Bowl and just you know clapping
and wow that was something you know we
just don't really notice you know we we
know we talked about Rome uh
earlier and something Rome did do was
the
Callum right they called it Brad and
circus it was there to distract people
from what was happening around them with
these performances or with the killing
of the Christians Gladiators all this
stuff yeah all they was being
entertained and cheap food give me my
entertainment and give me my food and
make it cheap y yep you know um it's
kind of interesting there was a
documentary that was made of Katie Perry
while she was like getting ready for
this and she's praised with her whole
cast Lady Gaga too yeah right before and
when you hear the prayer I mean it
sounds like a prayer that could be
offered to God like God help protect us
and do this and then you know come out
and do something so Blasphemous it's
crazy let's do a quick prayer I pray God
that you will look after us thank you so
much for this incredible opportunity and
we know it's because of you cuz you have
chosen us and we believe that we are
exactly where where we are supposed to
be today at this moment and we will be
present and conscious and we will smile
and we will live in this 12 and a half
minute
well the question is really who is she
praying toay to exactly you know if you
look into OU cultist Alice Bailey and
Helena
blotsky their writings could almost
sound Christian some sometimes because
they Al they do admit and say that they
worship Lucifer um but it's like wait a
minute you're not praying to the chrisan
God right right right yeah all right so
last one listen to what Beyonce said in
an interview with bet and I remember
right before I performed I raised my
hands up and it was kind of the first
time I I felt something else come into
me and I knew that was going to be my
coming out
night and um I'm really kind of shy and
not really shy but more reserved and um
nothing like Sasha
but I guess I wouldn't be very
entertaining on the stage so Sasha comes
out and she's
fearless you know she can she can do
things that I cannot do when I'm in
rehearsal I mean I can try but then it
just doesn't happen I can sing notes and
sing Strong and do all these things that
when I'm just by myself I can't do so
like when you're getting ready to go on
stage performs is Sasha Fierce when did
she show up usually when I hear the
crowd when I put on my stilettos um when
like the the moment right before when
you're nervous and and that other thing
kind of takes over for you uhhuh and I
it's no different from anyone else I
feel like we all kind of have that that
thing that takes over when Beyonce is
again one of those celebrities who grew
up Christian seems to have lost sight of
their religious upbringing even going as
far as embracing satanic and Pagan
symbolism here the singer is seeing
dressed up in a motorcycle costume
hinting at the goat of baffet a symbol
of Satan she tends to throw up the
Illuminati triangles a lot and of course
she's dressed up as a sun goddess or has
had references to the Sun God on
numerous occasions in the ancient days
the Sun God was also known as Bale which
again is just another version of a god
that is technically Satan during her
2013 halftime show performance two faces
of the Gemini twins showed up in
Babylonian astronomy the Stars Pollock
and Castor were known as the great twins
their names were Lio era Andes Lum a
meaning the mighty king and the one who
has risen from the underworld both names
are titles of nural a major Babylonian
God of plague and pestilence who was
king of the underworld I'm sure you can
figure out who the king of the
underworld is supposed to be
know it's it's just amazing this is what
I really mean by like if you could go
back in time and look at what a
Babylonian worship ceremony looked like
I guarantee you you'd have been like
I've seen this before yeah dude yeah and
for those who are still confused Sasha
is not a stunt double yeah somebody yeah
somebody taking over that's some taking
over yeah and she says that all of us do
it and like I'm not so sure about that
wow there's a lot of alter egos you know
Nicki Minaj she talked about her alter
egos Roman Roman and just when he takes
over he's like an angry guy and stuff
like that and she I mean she speaks of
him like he's a total entity and the oh
Eminem Eminem has one too
Shady Slim Shady yeah yeah I mean why
Always Babylon why are we always going
back to Babylon even when you're
portraying like Madonna did it has
origins in Babylon I think the number
one thing that Satan
knows to try and entice people is
worshiping other than God mhm I think
the number one Commandment that God gave
Thou shalt have no other gods before me
is literally number one because God's
like look if you if you get this one
wrong it's going to just trickle down to
everything else and these guys are
glorifying the gods that they serve and
the gods that have made them in these
powerful positions and you know I've
seen I've seen videos of Beyonce and all
the Witchcraft that her and her entire
family is involved in m there there is
her drummer basically put a restraining
order on Beyonce saying that she she
does extreme Witchcraft and was like
doing witchcraft against her drummer
because her drummer was like not seeing
eye to eye and stuff Lady Gaga she had a
personal assistant or something like
that and uh Lady Gaga made her sleep in
the bed with her but she would Lady Gaga
was like harassed by demons and then her
assistant also put a restraining order
against Lady Gaga and Lady Gaga was also
performing at the Super not this one but
she has right she has so it's like who
are these people that we're dealing with
that's why all of a sudden you've got
Kendrick Lamar yep who claims he's
Christian I put that in big big
quotations there what's that g to be
like yeah we'll have to see you got all
these people that have started out in
Christianity and look at where they end
up oh he's like Babylon and and it's
interesting that Babylon if you look at
Babylon it was the greatest Empire of
its time and also if you look at the D
Daniel what what in the Statue what was
representing Babylon was the head of
gold the head of gold yeah it was like
the head it was like the most important
thing which made King Nebuchadnezzar
really have a lot of pride in what he
had built right and we know that Pride
was what you know caused Satan to fall
MH right he he thought he was the
greatest and greater than God himself
yeah so when you have artists like that
go out and perform and they are just
doing it out of you know pure Pride
that's that's the God they're worshiping
right there yeah the god of self yeah
Revelation 14 gives us a pretty clear
picture of separating ourselves from
Babylon Babylon is Fallen pride is what
caus us to fall and that's the god that
these people in Babylon worshiped it was
Baal it was child sacrifices which I
mean we can go down a hole rabbit hole
but we know this kind of stuff happens
in these kind of Industries we know it
does um but child sacrifices I mean that
like you said there's there were
performances and and and
Temple where part of the performance was
to do that now now they're not there yet
however they're so scany clothed they do
certain movements and rituals and dance
movements that what that is designed to
portray that I remember when it was
Justin Timberlake and I don't remember
who he was with
they had a Mal malfunction of her Ward
malfunction and she she basically
exposed herself on national TV yeah he
pulled off a cup and she like here and
she looked shocked so people thought
that he did it on purpose or something I
don't know what it was but I would I
would doubt that nobody knew that in
advance because if you think about it as
a dude you're not just going to be like
oh let me grab here and oh but of course
it's not going to come off because it's
a one piece you know in advance it's
going to come off
I don't know we don't know what happened
there but it was it was definitely
another you know um candid exposure that
I think is all just part of the strategy
um and you know with where the world is
headed the Bible says we'll look at a
verse that in a second that we're
heading in the same direction as Sodom
and Gomorrah where this was like this is
nothing you know and we are headed in
that direction so we are Christians
let's take a look at the Bible should be
we watching this kind of stuff or not
Proverbs 4:14 and 15 15 sayso not enter
the path of the wicked and do not walk
in the way of evil avoid it do not
travel on it turn away from it and pass
on 2 Corinthians 3:18 but we all with
unveiled face beholding as in the mirror
the glory of the Lord by being
transformed into the same image from
glory to glory just as the spirit of the
Lord I know we've reiterated this over
and over and over again but I know
there's always new viewers so I want to
reiterate this again this is not just a
Biblical principle by beholding we
become changed it is a scientific
Principle as well something called
mirror neurons monkey see monkey do if
you do something my brain cannot
determine the difference between what
you're doing what I'm doing it reges it
is as I'm doing that so if I'm watching
the Super Bowl and I'm seeing people CL
clothe very scany dancing around I'm
doing that according to my brain and the
same as if they are showing Bale worship
Lucifer worship practices your brain
registered as doing that so maybe we
should not be watching this kind of
stuff lastly Luke 17: 26-30 and as it
was in the days of Noah so it will be
also in the days of the son of man
meaning Jesus second coming or before
his second coming they ate they drank
they married wives they were given in
marriage until the day that Noah entered
the Ark and the flood came and destroyed
them all likewise as it was also in the
days of lot they ate they drank they
bought they sold they planted planted
they built but on the day that the lot
went out of Sodom it rained fire and
brimstone from heaven and destroyed them
all even so it will be in the day when a
son of man is revealed and it's not all
bad things drinking eating selling
buying but it's about the distractions
yeah it's about the like a trojan horse
seems like it's good at first but then
on the inside it's just like things like
that all come for Destruction they're
not aware that judgment was it was
literally like at that moment well they
were told it was coming but they weren't
listening right and so they're go
carrying on life as normal and
disregarding where they were in the wake
of time rather than repenting like
Nineveh did you know like Hey we're
sorry and you know let's turn from it
they continued in that vein yeah yeah
and I like what Felipe is saying it's
not like these things are bad but
clearly what they were doing here was
bad meaning there is a way to eat and
drink and buy and sell and marry and
give in marriage in a worldly way and in
a Christlike Godly biblical way right
and and as we are Christians we are
looking forward to the second coming of
Jesus so we need to align all of those
things we do in everyday life according
to the Bible and how God is asking us to
live because we are therefore
proclaiming I believe Jesus is coming
soon we are testifying that he is the
true God and not Bale meaning Lucifer or
Satan and that that we are awaiting his
return that we love him um so in a way
we need to be seeing okay what what is
this world doing and let's flee from
that let's run from sin let's get away
from it and we know this is from the
world and so our DU due diligence our
duty as Christians is to run to Jesus
and run away from this stuff avoid the
appearance of evil and whether you eat
whether you drink do everything for the
GL the glory of
God all right let us know what you guys
think in the comments do you think the
Super Bowl is just like you know any
other performance or is there some kind
of a hidden message behind it is it a
bale Satan Lucifer worshiping
performance let us know make sure you
hit like subscribe and also if you want
to support our ministry thank you so
much you can do so by going to ls. av/
or patreon.com
Light Studios and and we've got some
cool merch that you can buy on lightwear
do shop light exposing Darkness
Ephesians 511 you can't buy Scotty's
though he made that himself you can't
buy the panda t-shirt but you cany buy
light exposing Darkness U thank you guys
so much for watching uh thank you for
tuning in and we'll see you guys next
time
[Music]
oh